[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es wieder eine richtig
leckere sonntags torte und zwar eine
mandarine torte mit einer quark sahne
und mohn auf einem lockeren biscuit und
ich muss dazu sagen die inspiration habe
ich aus dem neuen simply hilft und zwar
war da eine joghurt torte drin wo ist
sie denn hier
und dieser joghurt torte habe ich ja
sozusagen als inspiration genommen
ich wollte eigentlich eins zu eins nach
machen aber ich hatte kein joghurt da
also haben meine quartett draus gemacht
und star latina als bindemittel das
nämlich nicht ganz so gerne habe ich
dann abgenommen und es hilft das gibt es
glaube ich auch überall ja genau
und da drauf oder hier drinnen da seht
ihr auch da ist ein gewinnspiel drin da
könnt ihr nämlich einen backtag mit mir
zusammen gewinnen und unseren
kreuzworträtsel und vor allem noch ein
interview mit drin ich glaube online
gibt's das komplette interview und hier
drinnen sind auszüge davon ja genau das
habe ich die rezepte sehr an gelacht
wird auch in bagdad eine kurze
geschichte wird eine ganz kurze
geschichte so ist es wird bestimmt ein
richtig cooles event und vor allem ist
das gewinnspiel noch bis zum 31 12 2001
also wie gesagt die torte habe ich schon
beschrieben ich würde jetzt direkt
einmal starten mit dem bissig und zeigt
euch hier freunde der tat muss um die
titelprämie für den biskuit brauche ich
zwei eier 2 esslöffel heißes wasser eine
prise salz etwas man den extrakt 60
gramm zucker und 75 gramm ihren für den
biskuit gebe ich jetzt zuerst die zwei
eier in eine rührschüssel ihr könnt für
den bizkit die eier auch treppen und das
ganze separat aufschlagen aber das muss
gar nicht sein wenn ihr einfach lange
genug hören jetzt noch das heiße wasser
rein
statt der macher könnt ihr auch zb
espresso nehmen die prise salz
etwas vanille und natürlich auch deren
zucker und jetzt wird die maße für etwa
fünf bis sieben minuten krems gerührt
[Musik]
jetzt ist die eier zuckermasse schön
cremig fluffig könnte man auch sagen
viel spaß macht laufe ich wer sagt schon
fluch
ich will es ganz genau wenn ich jetzt
hochgekommen dann melde dich jetzt kann
ich das meer noch unterheben und das war
hier einfach kurz 7 war ich nehme mir
immer das mädel vom globus und das muss
man irgendwie nicht 7 schon wirklich
ganz ganz feines mehl aber ganz normales
weizenmehl und es wird jetzt ganz kurz
untergehoben
[Musik]
und jetzt kommen sie bis führt masse in
meinen und vorbereiteten ringen den habe
ich bereits auf 20 cm eingestellt
[Musik]
und so kommt der biscuit jetzt in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 190 grad ober
unterhitze für etwa 12 bis 16 minuten
[Musik]
der biss für das gebacken und ich habe
jetzt auch abkühlen lassen
jetzt nehme ich ihn vom blech herunter
die backform habe ich bereits mit dem
backform messer gelöst es kommt darauf
an torten ritter und da kommt jetzt noch
mal einen bug ring außen rum
den habe ich bereits gesäubert und jetzt
kann ich das so erstmal zur seite
stellen und zeigt euch hier vorne die
zutaten für die füllung für die füllung
brauche ich 350 gramm magerquark zwei
esslöffeln honig 60 gramm puderzucker
eine prise zimt 400 g schlagsahne etwas
vanille extrakt ich habe ich noch
sonderfahrt 30 kommunen und eine
unbehandelte orange ich nehme zwar erst
einmal die sahne und wenn sie jetzt ein
bisschen verrühren und dann mit seiner
partei schlagen und dann immer einfach
pro 100 gramm sahne immer einen
teelöffel salz
[Musik]
diese ist jetzt steigt kann ich kurz zur
seite stellen
und jetzt kann ich in einer separaten
schüssel die quarkmasse darin sieht ganz
klar soll ein ganz guter
feuchtigkeitsspender seien daher habe
ich den immer gerne im gesicht da kommt
jetzt der puderzucker mit rein und der
honigbiene hole ich geschmack nicht so
gerne mögen dann könnte ihn auch gerne
weglassen
aber ich finde es passt einfach super zu
torte
dann eine prise zimt und vanille und
jetzt könnt ihr noch den abrieb und den
saft von orange dazu geben und da ist
ganz wichtig dass die orange unbehandelt
ist
[Musik]
und hier gebe ich jetzt auch für
telefonate teelöffel vier teelöffel
sonderfahrt rein und kann die creme dann
verrühren
[Musik]
ich habe vergessen den orangensaft
mitzuzählen der auch so etwa 100
milliliter ich mache mir noch zwei
teelöffel rhein ihr merkt es einfach
wenn die creme schon fest wird dann
reicht auf jeden fall
[Musik]
und jetzt kann ich hier die sahne und
auch den mond unter helfen
[Musik]
und wenn ihr dann alles sorgfältig
verrührt habt kommt die komplette creme
einfach auf den biskuit boden und stand
gar nicht so glatt streichen
[Musik]
und wenn die torte so glatt ist können
wir sie abdecken und dann für etwa vier
stunden in den kühlschrank stellen
[Musik]
die torte ist jetzt gut durch gekühlt
und jetzt kann ich sie auf die torten
platte meiner wahl sitzen
das geht am besten mit einer palette
und jetzt kann ich den bug ring
entfernen geht am besten mit einem
sackmesser und jetzt kann ich sie fett
dekorieren und dafür habe ich jetzt hier
2000 mandarinen bereits abtropfen lassen
ihr könnt natürlich auch frischem an der
rede nehmen und die schälen und heute
ich finde es ein bisschen zu umständlich
das hat das wurde hier schon für mich
erledigt und jetzt lege ich dir einfach
ganz willkürliche drauf
[Musik]
man kann die torte jetzt so lassen oder
sie noch mit etwas aprikosenmarmelade
beträufeln wenn man möchte
die habe ich jetzt bereits erwärmt und
das ist eine ds fein passiert und ohne
stückchen und die kann ich jetzt ein
bisschen drüber streichen da bekommen
die mandarinen nochmal im glanz und ich
kann es auch am rand ein bisschen runter
laufen lassen
[Musik]
morath bereits schon die ganze zeit also
was bei der torte ganz ganz wichtig ist
ist die kühl zeit also wirklich
mindestens vier stunden am besten aber
auch über nacht die können dann nämlich
echt gut vorbereiten so richtig lecker
aus ihrem ich mir einen mohrenkopf hatte
irgendwie das heißt nicht morgen kommt
halt eine talkshow quasi dies schon jean
todt
[Musik]
ich habe ja schon die creme wird die
torte haben sich noch nicht erinnert
mich voll anderem joghurt also obwohl
ich jetzt keine joghurt creme wird so
eine quark sahne war super tolles und
bosch mit die genial und ich haben wir
noch gedacht nun und diesmal tochter
ariane lässt er ist nicht ganz richtig
geflüchtet ist gar nicht gedacht das
stimmt normalerweise packe ich ja nicht
so leckere torten da recht hat ihn
gerade echt gefälscht da ist man
lieblingszutaten wie also hab ich auf
dem mond aber da ist kein geld da
drinnen crunchy und ich fühle mich frei
legen
das macht nicht weil wir müssen noch
gleich noch ein paar fotos machen falls
sie aber auch eine torte backen möchte
die zum reinlegen ist dann schaut auf
meinem blog vorbei sallys - glocke etr
steht das rezept noch mal ganz genau
oder eben auch in der zeitschrift wobei
ich wie gesagt dass ein bisschen
abgewandelt habe aufgrund anderer
zutaten und ich wünsche euch ganz viel
spaß beim nachmachen vielleicht machte
er beim gewinnspiel mit und ich drücke
euch auf jeden fall die daumen ich
glaube das kreuzworträtsel das völlig
selber auch noch aus mal gucken ob es
einfacher oder schwieriger ist ich lieb'
kreuzworträtsel vielleicht gewünscht hat
mir selber nachdem ich es einfach ein
vielleicht gewinn diesen tag mit mir
selber genau ich mache jetzt einfach wie
heute habe ich glaube ich bin
ausgeschlossen
na ja gar nicht vor wie es trotzdem
also ich geb dir gleich noch ein stück
vorher machen wir bilder und ich freue
mich aufs nächste mal bis dann habe ich
gerade eine halbe miete glaubt ja
wahrscheinlich lieber noch ein stück ja
aber erst vortrags kommt hier bei aufbau
und dann kriegst noch mal okay tschüss
[Musik]